now on to California where the Los
Angeles city council who ignited
widespread outrage with racist remarks
caught on tape has resigned under heavy
heavy pressure in a statement Nuri
Martinez said this in part I wanted to
see a change in my community and fight
for my neighbors this is what it has
been about all along two other
counselors heard on the same tape are
ignoring calls for them to step down
Mark Strassman is in Los Angeles with
more on this story Mark good morning to
you
good morning to you Gail Nuri Martinez
is gone but Nuri Fury the city-wide
outrage over this leaked tape Mega one
especially since those two other council
members on that tape refused to resign
their conversation was offensive
possibly illegal too a backroom meeting
about City redistricting and
California's attorney general is now
looking into it
the investigation announced Wednesday
we'll look into whether three LA City
Council Members violated state or
federal voting rights laws for
conversations like the one you're about
to hear
on a secretly recorded audio tape local
labor leader Ron Herrera discusses
redistricting with former city council
president Nuri Martinez both resigned
their posts this week I get what we have
to do right this massage to create
districts that benefit you all right and
the future but we got to figure out Mark
seat too that year World recording often
coarse and racist was obtained by the LA
Times it suggests Martinez gaming up
potential ways to divvy up the District
of disgrace councilman Mark Ridley
Thomas
and the African-Americans look at this
as a hostile takeover because he's gone
so we'll have to figure that out because
politically they're going to come out
Ridley Thomas is suspended from his
position and facing trial scheduled to
begin next month on federal bribery
charges he's pleaded not guilty there's
rot in LA City there's just no other way
to talk about it Jessica Levinson is an
election law expert at Loyola Marymount
University in Los Angeles these comments
are not just vile they're not just
racist they're also potentially legally
problematic what we have are discussions
not just about increasing Latino voting
power but taken in context potentially
also about deluding African-American
voting power and that's where you get a
potential legal issue
what's striking about Martinez's
resignation statement she apologized
only to her staff nothing to anyone else
she offended including another Council
member's family and his adopted black
son whom she called in Spanish a little
monkey
it's really unbelievable Gail
it really is it really is Mark seems
like that apology needed to go a little
step further but we thank you yeah mark
thank you very much